jen saki you know jan saki she is the
white house press secretary uh she is a
woman who is completely incapable of
saying anything true and i'm fairly
certain that her prediction here also
will turn out not to be true she says
that old joe confused muddled pudding
for a brain joe biden that he is going
to run again in 2024. we've got a quote
here from the hill president biden
intends to run for re-election in 2024
white house press secretary saki
confirmed on monday following a flurry
of reports on discussions among
democrats about whether he would follow
through on a bid for a second term
that's his intention saki told reporters
confirming reports that biden has been
telling advisors and staff that he plans
to run again in 2024. biden would be 82
at the start of his second term if
re-elected he was already the oldest
individual to be inaugurated when he was
sworn in in january and his poll numbers
have steadily declined amid
dissatisfaction with the state of the
economy and rising prices in particular
okay let's be clear here joe biden is
not running for a second term i do not
believe that joe biden will even finish
this term we are only ten or so months
into term number one his cognitive
abilities have obviously uh failed
faster than they intended and they
clearly knew something was wrong with
him there is a scandal brewing as i
always say the scandal is the
non-scandal the fact that not everyone's
talking about this at all times that is
the scandal the way they can basically
take your eye off something that you
really can see that is the scandal
around joe biden on top of the fact that
the presidency has been an abject
disaster no matter what they tell you oh
they're telling you how great the
economy is gas prices parts of la over
five dollars a gallon we know about the
supply chain stuff let's not even talk
about afghanistan anymore like
we all know all the stuff we know all
that i do not believe he will run again
obviously it's just nonsense but that's
just sort of political posturing and
media lap dog sort of bs but as i said
at the top of the show
when i saw the story i said why don't we
find a clip of joe biden having one of
his joe biden moments and i think we
just found this is about a two minute
clip you may remember this i believe
this is the same speech
in which biden referenced corn pop okay
i think it's the same exact speech as
corn pop but this is a different part a
lesser known part of the corn pop speech
uh here's joe biden just if you don't
laugh during this no no not if you don't
laugh i laugh hysterically again that's
why i have the tissues here i was
laughing hysterically my guys were
laughing hysterically i just want you to
really listen to this
and
you tell me if this makes any sense what
this man said in front of these people
for two minutes here we go i learned a
lot
and i learned that uh
it makes a difference this was the
diving board area
and i was one of the guards
and they weren't allowed it was a three
meter board and you fell off sideways
you landed on the damn the darn cement
over there
and corn pop was a bad dude
and he ran a bunch of bad boys
and i did yeah he and back in those days
the shot things have changed
one of the things he had to use if you
use pomade in your hair you had to wear
a bathing cap
and so he was up on the board one listen
to me i said hey esther you off the
board or i'll come up and drag you off
well he came off
and he said i'll meet you outside my car
this was mostly these were all public
housing behind it
my car there was a gate out here i
parked my car outside the gate
and i he said i'll be waiting for you
he's waiting for three guys in straight
razors
not a joke
there's a guy named bill wright mouse
the only white guy and he did all the
pools he was the mechanic
and i said what am i going to do he said
come down here in the basement where
mechanics where where all the pool
filter is you know the chain used to be
a chain that went across the deep end
and he cut off a six foot length of
chain he fold up he said you walk out
with that chain
and you walk to the car and say you may
cut me man but i'm gonna wrap this chain
around your head
i said you kidding me
he said no if you don't don't come back
and he was right so i walked out with
the chain
and i walked up to my car
and they had those days used to remember
the straight razors bang them on the
curb get them rusty put them in a rain
barrel get them rusty
and i looked at him but i was smart then
i said first of all i said when i tell
you get off the board you get off the
board and i'll kick you out again but i
shouldn't have called you esther
williams i apologize for that
i apologize but i know that apology is
going to work he said you apologize to
me i said i apologize for that not for
throwing you out but i apologize for
what i said
he said okay close the straight razor my
heart began to beat again
there are people
who believe that that man is running the
united states of america
and i'd like to have what they're having
because it must be
beautiful to live in that world
what the high hell is he talking about
what is going on there i do stand
corrected that actually was the corn pop
clip when we showed it right before the
show we missed those first 10 seconds
that was the corn pie i don't know who
corn pop is i don't know who mouse is
the rusty chains and the guy and the
pomade with the what is he talking about
and the best part of that
is go watch it again later
he rambles for two minutes nobody in
their right mind please if you're if
you're watching right now and you're in
the live chat uh please someone tell me
what that all meant like sum it up for
me can someone sum it up for me but the
best part of all that is he rambles
completely incoherently in a deranged
way for two minutes and then when he
gets to whatever the punch line is which
i'm still unclear what it was everyone
laughs oh yes well of course with the
chains and the mouse and corn pop and
the
yeah he's going to be president in 2024
they're all just liars they're such
freaking liars uh but joe's got problems
and joe believe it or not he's even got
problems
here in crazy los angeles this is video
from downtown
los angeles today people are protesting
vaccine mandates and they don't like joe
[Applause]
i just want to be very clear here
brandon has a much much better chance of
running in 2024 than joe biden like much
better chance